>> Sandra: FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER FACEBOOK REMOVED ONE OF
THE PRESIDENT’S POSTS.
TWITTER DOING THE SAME SAYING
THE PRESIDENT’S MESSAGE BREAKS
THEIR RULES AGAINST SPREADING
MISINFORMATION ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS.
JOINING US NOW AT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT KELLYANNE CONWAY.
GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
THERE IS A DEBATE HAPPENING
WHETHER OR NOT FACEBOOK OR
TWITTER SHOULD BE ARBITERS OF
TRUTH AND DECIDE WHAT IS FACT
AND FICTION.
WE CAN HAVE THAT TALK IN A
MOMENT.
THE LATEST CDC NUMBERS ON
CORONAVIRUS CASES IN CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF 18.
UNDER 18 ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT
7.4% OF CONFIRMED CASES.
THAT IS UP 6.7% FROM TWO WEEKS
AGO AND UP NEARLY 6% FROM A
MONTH AGO.
SO KIDS ARE GETTING THIS
DISEASE, KELLYANNE.
>> YES, THEY ARE.
THANKFULLY MOST HAVE NEVER DIED.
EVERY PERSON WHO DIES IS A
TRAGEDY.
THOSE ARE NATIONAL NUMBERS.
NOT EVERY STATE, COUNTY OR
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THE SAME AND
SEE SO MANY PARENTS WHEN
THEY’RE SURVEYED, SANDRA, SAY
DO YOU FEEL LIKE IT’S SAFE TO
SEND YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER BACK
TO SCHOOL AND YES, PLEASE DO
THAT.
THEY’RE BEING BIG FOOTED BY ONE
HEALTH COMMISSIONER IN A COUNTY
OR SCHOOL BOARD OR A FEW IN THE
TEACHER’S UNION.
I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT EVERYBODY IS
SAYING HERE.
I’M ALSO HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
BASED ON THE COVID REPORT I
RECEIVED THIS MORNING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE OVERALL TEST
POSITIVITY RATE HAS DECLINED 8%
SINCE LAST WEEK AND 0 STATES
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE SINCE
TUESDAY.
AS DR. BIRX AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN SAYING WE’RE SEEING A
FLATTENING.
GOVERNOR DUCEY WAS HERE
YESTERDAY FROM ARIZONA SHOWING
A GREAT MODEL FOR THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAD A HUGE SURGE IN JUNE
AND TOOK ACTION.
>> Sandra: THE DEBATE NOW IS
OVER THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION BY THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT CHILDREN BEING NEARLY
IMMUNE.
HAVING -- UNDER 18 KIDS IN THIS
COUNTRY GET THE DISEASE 7.4% OF
THE TIME IS NOT NEARLY IMMUNE
AND YOU WANT TO DIAL DOWN TO
SPECIFIC STATES AND DISTRICTS
WHERE SCHOOLS ARE REOPENING,
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH CHILDREN.
I SPOKE TO THE GOVERNOR OF
MISSISSIPPI LAST NIGHT AND HE
SAID THE KIDS ARE SPREADING IT.
LISTEN.
>> WHAT’S HAPPENED IS MANY OF
THESE KIDS WHEN THEY STARTED
BACK TO SCHOOL EARLY LAST WEEK
CAME INTO THE SCHOOLS.
THEY CAME IN AND HAD THE VIRUS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE 100 STUDENTS
THAT ARE QUARANTINED NOW.
THOSE WHO WANT TO ATTACK
EVERYONE, LOOK AT THAT AS A
NEGATIVE.
I LOOK AT IT AS A POSITIVE.
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING WHERE
WE’VE IDENTIFIED POSITIVE
CASES, CONTACT TRACED THOSE
BACK AND TRYING TO PROTECT
THOSE KIDS.
>> Sandra: IS IT HELPFUL FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO TELL PARENTS
THAT CHILDREN ARE NEARLY IMMUNE
FROM THIS AND THEN HAVE IT
FACTUALLY SPREADING CHILD TO
CHILD IN PLACES LIKE
MISSISSIPPI WHERE THEY’VE
OPENED THE DOORS TO THE SCHOOLS?
>> THE PRESIDENT MAKES VERY
CLEAR USES THE NEW JERSEY
INFORMATION HE GOT FROM
DEMOCRAT PHIL MURPHY.
NEW JERSEY WAS THE SECOND
HARDEST HIT STATE FOR A WHILE
YOU’VE HAD ONE CHILD UNDER THE
AGE OF 18 THAT PASSED AWAY AND
IT HAD UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
THAT’S THE INFORMATION I HAVE.
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING CLEAR
THAT OVERALL THE AVERAGE AGE OF
THOSE WHO PASS FROM CORONAVIRUS
IS STILL AT 78.
OVER 40% OF THOSE WHO PASSED
AWAY WERE IN LONG TERM
FACILITIES AND NURSING HOMES.
I LEARNED THAT IN THE
CORONAVIRUS TASKS FORCE MEETING
IN THE OVAL OFFICE TWO DAYS AGO.
WE HAD THE TASK FORCE MEETING
IN THERE.
I LISTENED TO DR. REDFIELD AND
FAUCI AND BIRX.
WE HAVE TO MAKE CLEAR THAT WE
-- A LOCKDOWN AND SHUTDOWN MAY
WORK FOR BIDEN IN WILMINGTON
BUT DOESN’T WORK FOR OUR SCHOOL
CHILDREN.
WE KNOW FROM MANY HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
EXTENDED LOCK DOWNS AND NOT
BEING IN SCHOOL INCREASED SO
MANY OTHER MALADIES FOR THESE
CHILDREN.
>> Sandra: I GET THAT,
KELLYANNE.
THE POINT IS THE PRESIDENT IN
THAT INTERVIEW ON "FOX &
FRIENDS" YESTERDAY MORNING SAID
IT IS GOING TO GO AWAY.
LIKE THINGS GO AWAY.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING MANY
PEOPLE ARE TAKING ISSUE WITH
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE HIS OWN
HEALTH EXPERTS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, DR. FAUCI, DR. BIRX AND
OTHERS, THIS THE FAUCI’S WORDS.
I DON’T BELIEVE IT WILL
DISAPPEAR BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
HIGHLY TRANCE MYSELFIBLE VIRUS.
>> HE IS AND HE SHOULD BE
LISTENING TO HIM AS WELL.
WE DON’T LIKE TO HEAR THE FIRST
THINGS ON TV WHEN WE HAVE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE MEETINGS
AND DON’T HEAR CERTAIN THINGS
THERE AND WE CAN PRESSURE TEST
AND LEARN AS A TASK FORCE AND
THEN HEAR THEM FOR THE FIRST
TIME ON TV.
IT MEANS THE COUNTRY BENEFITS
WHEN WE UNDERSTAND THE FACTS
AND FIGURES HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THEY ARE BROUGHT UP
TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT AS SHOULD BE THE CASE.
LET ME MAKE THIS POINT.
WHEN TWITTER AS OF ALL PEOPLE I
IMAGINE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WORK AT TWITTER.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
WORKS FOR KAMALA HARRIS COME
OUT AND ANNOUNCE YOU ARE
BANNING THE PRESIDENT’S TWEET
AND TAKING IT DOWN.
THAT ITSELF SHOWS A POLITICAL
MOTIVATION.
AND I THINK WHAT MANY OF THESE
TECH COMPANIES ARE DOING NOW TO
THE PRESIDENT, TO
CONSERVATIVES, THE SHADOW
BANNING, THE SENSORING, THE
SELECTIVE ENGAGEMENT IS
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
WE GOT THREE YEARS WORTH OF
ELECTION SECURITY, ELECTION
SECURITY.
NOW WE’LL DO MAIL-IN BALLOTING,
WE’RE GOING TO SHUT DOWN THE
PRESIDENT’S TWITTER FEED AT
TIMES TEAM TRUMP GOT SHUT DOWN.
THE WHO, WHICH TOLD EVERYBODY
IN JANUARY NO EVIDENCE OF
HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION OF
COVID IS STILL UP ON TWITTER.
YOU’VE GOT -- I HAVE A WHOLE
LIST OF TWEETS FROM HERE THAT
ARE THE BIGGEST LIE OF THE LAST
10 YEARS SAID BY JOE BIDEN,
KEEP YOUR PLAN AND DOCTOR.
THAT’S PROBABLY IN A TWEET
SOMEWHERE.
>> Sandra: LET ME CLARIFY WHAT
YOU’RE SAYING AND I’LL PULL UP
THE FACEBOOK SPOKESPERSON ON
REMOVING THAT VIDEO INVOLVING
THE PRESIDENT.
VIDEO INCLUDES FALSE CLAIMS
THAT A GROUP OF PEOPLE IS
IMMUNE FROM CORONAVIRUS.
YOU SEEM TO BE POINTING OUT
MISINFORMATION SPREAD BY OTHER
PEOPLE, BY OTHER WORLD LEADERS,
ETC.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT THERE
IS A SPACE FOR FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER TO MONITOR AND IN SOME
CASES DELETE INFORMATION THAT
IS SPREAD LIKE THE PRESIDENT’S
OR WHOEVER ELSE THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO NAME RIGHT NOW, OR
SHOULD THEY NOT BE DOING IT AT
ALL?
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE STANCE?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE TO MAKE UP
THEIR MIND.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ABOUT THE TECH
COMPANIES.
WHY DO WE HAVE THE TECH
OVERLORDS TELLING US WHAT IS
AND IS NOT LEGITIMATE ON HEALTH
MATTERS.
THEY IMMEDIATELY TAKE ACTION
AGAINST SOME PEOPLE AND NEVER
OTHERS.
THAT’S SELECTIVE ENGAGEMENT.
IF THIS REALLY IS THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
THEY HIDE BEHIND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, IT SHOULD BE.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT HAS TEETH
THIS WEEK OR LAST WEEK.
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE SENT
TO THE SEC SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE WANT MORE
TRANSPARENCY.
WHY ARE PRO-LIFE VIDEOS TAKEN
DOWN ON VIDEO AND EXCLUDED FROM
FACEBOOK?
WHY ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO
DEFEND THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
YOU DON’T LIKE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT TELL CONGRESS TO DO
AWAY WITH IT.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT’S SELECTIVE
ENGAGEMENT, TWITTER, FACEBOOK,
MANY OF THE FORMS ARE OVERLY
ANTI-TRUMP.
I THINK WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS
THE PRESIDENT HAS OVER 200
MILLION FOLLOWERS ON ALL THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
HE HAS USED IT THE WAY NO OTHER
POLITICIAN HAS EVER USED IT AND
THEY DON’T LIKE THAT.
THEY DON’T LIKE THE FACT THAT
HE CAN USE THEIR PLATFORMS AS A
WAY TO REACH AMERICANS IN A WAY
THAT --
>> Sandra: THAT CAN BE DEBATED.
I WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF PACKAGE.
AS A RESULT OF EVERYTHING WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
THERE ARE SO MANY AMERICANS
STILL STRUGGLING.
SO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES TRYING
TO STAY AFLOAT IF THEY SURVIVE
WHAT WE’VE GONE THROUGH SO FAR.
IS MARK MEADOWS PUSHING THE
PRESIDENT INTO EXECUTIVE ACTION
ON THIS?
IT SEEMS LIKE CONGRESS IS
GETTING NOWHERE.
>> I THINK PELOSI AND SCHUMER
ARE PUSHING THE PRESIDENT TO
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
HE WON’T STAND BY WHILE
AMERICANS SUFFER ECONOMICALLY.
HE HAS TAKEN SUCH ROBUST ACTION
THROUGH THE CARES ACT,
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN RELIEF
TO THE STATES, ALL COMBINED TO
THE STATES, ALSO TO THE
HOSPITALS AND REIMBURSEMENT
OVER $150 BILLION AND COUNTING.
OF COURSE, TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
HE KEPT MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
AFLOAT NOT JUST SURVIVING BUT
THRIVING TO COVER THEIR
PAYROLLS.
LAST FRIDAY THE DEMOCRATS
GETTING IN THE WAY OF A ONE
WEEK EXTENSION OF $600.
WHY WAS THAT IMPORTANT?
JULY 31st.
WE’RE CONCERNED PEOPLE PAYING
THEIR BILLS IN AUGUST,
SEPTEMBER, OCTOBER.
THEY ONLY CARE HOW YOU VOTE IN
NOVEMBER.
>> Sandra: WHERE IS THE
PRESIDENT WILLING TO ACT ALONE
WITH EXECUTIVE ACTION?
>> HE CAN -- THERE ARE THINGS
HE CAN DO AND HE HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH HIS ECONOMIC TEAM
AND LAWYERS HERE, I KNOW THAT
AS FACT TO SEE IF HE CAN STAND
UP AND STAND IN WHERE CONGRESS
FAILS TO ACT.
THERE IS A REASON CONGRESS HAS
13% APPROVAL RATING.
WHEN THEY BOTHER TO SHOW UP FOR
WORK THEY DON’T GET ANYTHING
DONE.
IT SEEMS SO PARTISAN.
LEADER MCCONNELL HAS BEEN OUT
THERE DOING THIS, TIM SCOTT OF
SOUTH CAROLINA AND LAMARR
ALEXANDER WITH A GREAT SCHOOL
CHOICE BILL TO HELP THE
STUDENTS THAT RELY ON
SCHOLARSHIPS, OPPORTUNITIES AND
FREEDOM.
LET THE MONEY FOLLOW THE CHILD.
IF YOU CAN FIND A SCHOOL THAT’S
OPEN LET THE MONEY FOLLOW THE
CHILD.
IT IS THERE FOR THE STUDENTS,
NOT THE GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE TEACHERS, WE WANT --
THEY SEEM HELL BENT ON MAKING
IT A PARTISAN EXERCISE AND NOT
FOR THE PEOPLE ECONOMICALLY
SUFFERING.
>> Sandra: NEW GALLUP SURVEY ON
ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
ARE YOU SATISFIED OR
DISSATISFIED WITH THE WAY
THINGS ARE GOING IN THE UNITED
STATES AT THIS TIME?
ONLY 13% SAID THAT THEY’RE
SATISFIED.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT,
KELLYANNE.
>> 13% IS ABOUT THE APPROVAL
RATING.
WE’RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC AND SOCIAL UNREST.
THAT DOESN’T SURPRISE ME.
THE OTHER GALLUP NUMBER THAT
CAUGHT MY EYE IS THAT 9 IN 10
AMERICANS DON’T WANT TO DEFUND
THE POLICE 8 IN 10
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND HISPANIC.